Degh? High five? YES! BARF! BARF BARF BARF WOOF WOOF WOOF!!!
Imma barf!
Ugh. Please stop. Oh! God! Why?
YAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAARRRRRGH!
What have you done to me? My butt feels weird!
Am I a cat?
I'M A DOG BARF!
Heyyy.
ABRABRABRABRABRABRABRABRABRABRABRAH!
BOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!
(EEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEH) Hey? What's going on here? Uh oh! He seems mad! Ah! Oh! Oh no! OH NO! OH SHIT!
F**K YOU!
HAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHA!
WAFTHAFTHAFTHAFTHAFTHAFTHAFTHAFTHAF!
BABABABABABABABABABABA!
Errrrrrr bow woof. (Mrs. Dog?) Woof woof woof woof. (Awoooooooooooooooooo)
WOOF, BITCH!
Bow uuuuuuugh!
Say woof again! SAY WOOF AGAIN!
Engengeng. (slurp)
Hey Chica, what's going on?
I dunno.
Aaaaauuuuagh.
Dad, whyyyyyyyyyyy?
Ugh! Why did you make another one of these, Daaaaaaaad?